e aí é que este meu canal tudo bom vocês
mas um vídeo novo aqui em que beleza já
pode achar aquele jovem é maravilhoso
ele sonha com do chocolate crocante eu
gosto demais é uma coisa que acontece
com todo mundo é passar vergonha passar
vergonha e uma das coisas que eu fico
mais fundo como acontece é quando tem
que ajudar a mim eu sei que você que tá
aí já passou por essa situação tem vez
que você está no meio da rua e tal e se
vai atravessar o sinal é a segunda
pessoa cadeirante ou uma pessoa com
deficiência visual não sei você vai lá
na pessoa querendo ajudar e tal é a
pessoa que responde não for muito grossa
aí você vai lá que ajuda a pessoa e tal
só que as pessoas que garantem uma coisa
na cabeça então não sei o que a pessoa
tem um monte já chegar a quem né ajudar
bongi mas já chegaram empurrando na
senhora dona elza louca ou r serra na
galp primeiro porque a pessoa que é
cadeirante ela não sabe quais são suas
intenções ao querer um raio
então a gente aí eu não tinha nada hoje
não tô de boa pessoa que tem deficiência
visual realmente atalaia a pessoa chega
atravessando ela está só que as pessoas
esquecem que é uma coisa maravilhosa que
deus nos deu chamada boca que serve para
além de você falar merda muita merda
você pode perguntar é isso mesmo nem
perguntar você perguntando você pouco a
pessoa de constrangimento você ir pouco
de constrangimento e pouco músicos tb
não tem mais procedimento no mundo as
pessoas foi muito feliz na terra inteira
então faça isso vai voltar a acontecer
pra vocês um dia estava no shopping
total e tinha um cara lacta brasiliano
um desenho um esquadro as coisas lá eu
peguei meu celular não é beleza deixa eu
tirar uma foto e quando voltei lá que eu
só vi o pintor assim ó
ele dê permissão que há uma cara só não
é que eu tenho uma página que eu queria
só apostar pra galera vim aqui eu lhe
dei permissão eu saí ponto chave de
veículo estava só querendo ajudar e
postar no facebook galé vem aqui tem um
cara é um trabalho muito bacana e tal eu
queira automatic mousses papel é isso só
que depois eu me liguei que o errado foi
o que o prefeito quem perguntar primeiro
a chegar fácil moça poder após tirar uma
foto que eu tenho uma página eu posso
divulgar a galera pode vim aqui pra
fazer um desenho o senhor ele é falar
beleza pode tirar fotos mas não chego lá
e vou tirar foto o cara vai lá saber o
que eu vou fazer essa foto vai então
convida dúvidas pergunte me uma pessoa
meio da rua vou querer ajudar chega na
primeira ela pergunta se ela quer a
junta não quiser ajuda e se quiser ficar
ali onde é lotado
eu não quero sair daqui [ __ ]
se eu quiser passar eu pego essa cadeira
é o bota já aqui agora como eu quero
ficar
olha quebra e se ela quiser testar seus
próprios limites quer saber que ela vai
se ela já foi o eficiente há muito tempo
que tiver que tomar é sobre a nato conta
com a china do himalaia na então galera
essa é a mensagem do vídeo se você tiver
com do rei alguma coisa pega
quero ajudar primeiras opções de ajuda
ajudou beleza você foi lá então uma
pessoa não que isso ajuda beleza você
tentou eu podia no céu já vai morar numa
casa com cerâmica o que vale é a
intenção mas pergunte primeiro uma coisa
que você faz você ajuda muito você nem
perguntar é compartilhar esse vício ele
compartilhar marca e um amigo dois então
esse vídeo foi o último e se divertiu da
um jovem gay do sitar amenizado com
açúcar e comente aqui embaixo você já
passou algum situação situação e comente
aqui embaixo você já passou alguma
situação constrangedora como eu também
já passei se você não está inscrito
nacional seja saber que se faz nessa
coisa clique em inscrever se você vai
está inscrevendo neuton e daum
compartilhada lá que você não ajuda para
[ __ ]
o então é isso aí valeu galera pegar o
volante o joinha foco cada desfocado
focando foto da rainha na bahia
mãe é mãe
avaí e bahia só que ela vai
isso aqui é o meu mano mc o que john e
esse km single essa galera que está em
paz são paulo aqui ou na promoção à i
confere que o cliper clicando aqui na
minha mãe aqui ó
é só clicar aqui galera e é isso aí
mesmo
é isso aí galera é nossa